I will open the session
on subcommittee work session on House
Bill 580 FN establishing a children's
vision screening initiative within the
State Medicaid
Program um so we have no members of the
public here uh to give testimony so um I
guess we should probably Dive Right In
uh how would you like to approach this I
should I State my concerns and then we
can kind of work from there or would you
you I think be helpful to myself Mr
chair to have you voice your concerns
and try to weed those into how I can
respond to it yeah that would give you
more of a an opportunity to respond to
those so or you can respond as we go if
you prefer um we can keep this pretty
informal um
so I guess my first observation on going
back through the bill and I I I
apologize because I had forgotten a lot
of detail about it but my first
concern is that the fundamentally the
title of this bill is is
misleading um this is not just an
expansion under
Medicaid um in fact all three Medicaid
plans that cover children in New
Hampshire currently cover Vision Care
um this is what this bill really is
about is creating a compulsory vision
screening requirement for all all
students in public schools in New
Hampshire
um so whether you think that's a good
idea or a bad idea it's it's it's quite
different from the title of the bill and
so I I guess I feel like we need to be
focused on addressing whether or not
that is proper and whether it is
implemented properly
um so under the Medicaid Program
children up to 19 years meaning zero to
18 um get you know their entitled to
vision
coverage
um non-medicaid Pro program uh
non-medicaid
families uh will be required to get a
vision screening and for most that will
not cost them anything out of pocket
because vision screening is considered
to be an essential health benefit under
the Affordable Care Act yes and no
yes and no depending on the health plan
or yes and no depend did some research
last night after our call and what I
found out and I brought it with me is
that under the state exchange programs
and ones that are done through certain
agencies it's a requirement if you will
it's part of the package however if
you're under Arisa plans that is one of
the things that they don't have to cover
okay and most of the people in the state
are covered by self-employed so I
brought the documentation so um the
chair could read through this as well so
I wasn't misunderstanding or misreading
it okay so I think we actually came to
the same conclusion because I said for
those with ACA compliant HealthCare
coverage correct there's no cost however
there are people who have n health plans
that are not ACA compliant in the in so
far as they don't conform to that
essential health benefit requirement you
brought up one example another example
is IAL medical sharing plans um like a
medical sharing Ministry like meta share
I don't know if meta share specifically
covers uh Vision or not I probably
should because that's the plan I'm on
but um I I don't believe that it does
um so so I guess in in reviewing this I
I sort of really started to reframe it
as this is really not about establishing
a benefit under the Medicaid programs so
much as it because that already exists
what this is really about is saying we
want to make vision screening compulsory
for children in public schools in New
Hampshire the only out in this case is a
religious
exemption and the reason that that
language appears the way it does is
because if you look at
RSA
32 um this is the section of Statute
that that part of the bill is seeking to
amend this basically just copies that
part of the bill so or that part of the
RSA so RSA 200 section
says you have to have a every child
shall have a physical exam upon their
first upon their entry into a public
school system or first Contact first
entry into a public school
system unless there is a religious basis
for for opting out of that and so
basically they just just copied that
language and I concur with what you're
saying I think you're hit the nail on
the head quite frankly that is it's a
it's a form of a mandate it's not so
much the economics the question about
the Mandate however I believe we tackled
this issue before that no screening or
health any kind of an exam could be done
without the parental approval so
therefore the parents do have the option
to opt out of
this okay they don't
so
that so that raises the question and
it's a question I had about this bill I
have a concern about the bill that
parents can opt out but there's no
notification provision in the bill is
there a notification requirement
elsewhere in statute because I know we
have it for dental uh but I wasn't clear
on whether we have it broadly speaking
for other medical procedures I went to
bed before I get to that point okay so
but I do agree with what you're saying I
think we need to go back and look at
that
because give you two examples why I'm
concerned with this it's building the
awareness and part of it is my wife was
a school nurse for many years and she
did many hearing and vision screenings
but she only did it when the parent
approved of it so there was a card it
was sent to the parents of the child and
the parent had to be very specific and
check off everything they wanted to be
done if it wasn't checked off she would
not do it okay so even though it was
before we had this whole issue of
parenteral approval she relied upon the
parents giving her permission to begin
with but more importantly I have
a
granddaughter who was struggling
struggling in school and it wasn't until
the second almost the end of the second
year that someone said wait a minute she
can't see the
Blackboard and if someone had taken the
time to do a screening when she came
into the school she she would not have
lost two years of her academic life
struggling because she couldn't have
glasses and once they put the glasses on
her she wow that's a chalkboard I can
actually
see and in my my daughter is not
uneducated they don't lack the economics
of it they lack the awareness of it and
that's my concern is how do we build
greater awareness amongst the the
population in order to be sure that
they're taken care
of so
we had talked briefly about this
beforehand and one of my so I I think
having listened to this and talking to
the chairman just before you got in here
representative Merchant was basically in
my mind two broad categories one is
philosophically a mandate for
screening but then the second part of it
which I agree with also is that there
are certain parts of this could be
tightened up so to speak so you know
things like in my mind in the on the
first page the bottom there should
provide reimbursement for and then it
says list all the people I I think that
really ought to be just changed to
Simply qualified providers because
that's what we're talking about you know
because it reminding me today when I was
at CVS getting my uh coid vaccine it was
done by a technician which 10 years ago
would never have been done so the scope
of practice is going to change going
forward for so many people in healthcare
and if that's appropriate then I would
basically just get rid of listing those
that can give it and basically say you
know qualified providers you know that
sort of thing when we talked about this
previously about the religious exemption
on the on the second page there I would
have just ended that sentence as at the
guardian objects there to in writing
period that's all there is you you
object to it it doesn't have to give a
reason you just object to it that's fine
but I I think we can get rid of
something like that so I agree with the
fact that there may be things that need
to be tightened up but on the other hand
even at the top you know the chairman
mentioned that this is misleading in its
title perhaps again it would address the
uh potential compulsory nature of the
bill which it really is when you talk
about it if you change that title to
establish an AM manatory children screen
children vision screening initiative
that's what we're talking about so I
mean little things like that could be
tightened up a little bit to make it
more palatable but then we have to get
beyond the question of philosophically
do we even want to have a compulsory or
mandatory
screening from a clinical perspective
and like yourself I have a daughter who
had stabismus but once the stabismus is
corrected at an early age the
development of the child is much
enhanced it also is one of those things
where if you can pick up with you know
um things like you know um red reflex
examinations and a good opthalmologic
examination you might pick up things
early on retinoblastoma glaucoma things
that could be corrected very early with
good success that if not treated up to
you know at the time of um when you
first could Discover it could lead to
potential problems down the road and
also then becomes a savings down the
road as we all know preventative care
tends to save you know um um significant
dollars in monies in health care if we
can detect things early and treat them
in their more um in their early stages
so I guess my my thought was that there
may be some tightening up necessary as
we've all as we've talked about Rec
right now but then my question would be
even if we did then get to you know some
tightened language you know whether it
be a different terminology or qualified
provider that sort of thing it it still
comes down to potentially a an impass of
the compulsory nature of the bill so I
guess that's where I would you know in
in in interim study may be the right way
to go but it still may also lead to the
same
conclusion I think it's going to lead
the same
conclusion and you raise a lot of good
points re of
Murphy my thought is that it's really
not a
mandate it's is a mandate is something
in which you have no option to opt
out if you allow for the parent or the
guardian whoever it would
be
the ability to opt out of it then you
really don't have per se a mandate so
therefore as long as that is in the bill
that the parent or Guardian has the
option to opt out I think I could live
with the issue of having the screening
being done it doesn't have to be done by
a school nurse who raise a good point
because minus standing and well child
visits that a lot of this is happening
so if they have documentation that the
physician the pediatrician has been
doing the screenings they don't have to
reinvent the wheel just bring a
documentation from your physician that
they have had the screenings so
potentially so potentially then you
could you know again
philosophically um get over the um
mandate or compulsory nature hurdle by
basically saying in the language that
prior to any examination ocular you know
opthalmologic examination or screening
it has to have parental consent to do so
correct period
period that would
certainly that would certainly move me
closer
to I I I I don't want to I don't want to
say uh that it would move me all the way
to to supporting it there are a number
of other things but I'm I'm going to
agree with both of you wholeheartedly
that I think catching these problems
early can is not only beneficial in
terms of the the cost that that it saves
but also just the human suffering that
it saves so um so it certainly should be
encouraged
um the so let me let me tell you about
some other concerns I had as I was going
through the bill um and some of these I
think I put these as other issues in my
my notes here because I think most of
them are actually minor um minor and
easily fixed um one of them is as part
of the budget for the B
well the budget's already been passed so
that would just be a language change
that needs to happen um the commissioner
shall adopt rules um I always get
nervous when I see that we're
authorizing an agency to adopt
rules um just on General
principle um there is also a training
requirement that would be established
under this bill and essentially it it
creates a sort of
um list of approved providers and I this
isn't an objection so much as it's a
question is
um are we potentially
narrowing the the number of providers
who would be quote unquote authorized to
perform Vision screenings by by
including that in the bill I I would I
would say no only because I think
that as medicine has evolved over the
years in my experience is that we have
expanded the scope of practice of and
even increased the U the variety of
providers you know like uh Physical
Therapy 2 versus physical therapy one or
LPNs you know in their their scope of
practice we've actually increased the
number of titled or
named providers to do certain work in
healthcare so if you have a training
program
then that ties into what I said before
about don't list optometrist or
physician just say qualified provider
and that way if you have a pro you know
if you have a a requisite U training
program that ties into then the
qualified
provider and so I so one of my other
objections or actually not objection
questions was about the list of specific
individuals you have you would be
addressing that question by just simply
saying qualified provider right um
having said that
um I now have to find this the section
specifically uh it's on the first page
of the
bill um lines
18 I'm sorry 19
2021 the department shall develop a list
of approved training
programs and then upon implementation
the the department shall provide a list
of qualified providers participating in
the State Medicaid Program to Primary
Care providers in the vision screening
initiative so
this kind of raises questions to me as
to who's who's on the list who's off the
list are we creating an additional
training requirement for providers who
may have been qualified all along and
may have been performing Vision
screenings all along but now we're
saying you got to go to the extra
training to be on the list and if you're
not on the list you can't be included in
this that's my sure I concur with you
okay well I I would push back only a
little bit saying that if if people have
been doing Vision screenings like if
they have done other exams in the school
setting but they weren't competent or
they weren't up to date with the
training protocols that are
required
then I would say I don't think it's
going to exclude those that have already
done it my my I would be very surprised
to see anybody who's done this regularly
in the school setting not be able to
take a simple qualific qualification
either exam or you know um certification
process to make sure that they are
qualified to do this
so I don't think it would eliminate
anybody but I think having a training
program and then having a list that goes
to the public school systems would say
like when you're looking for a pharmacy
you look on the list of CVS or Walgreens
or whatever and say there's one right
there in Lebanon
I need somebody to do vision screening
or contract with them through the school
board or through the school itself who
in the region does that it would be a
list so I think it would actually be
very helpful for a school system to know
who their vision screening providers are
um and I I think it would it would it
would just be very helpful in fact you
know it's easy to do because it's all
electronic they have a list of them if
you if you can do the vision screening
you're qualified you should be on a list
preferred provider meaning that you it
also would be good for Medicaid or any
insurance re reimbursement to know that
and they I think they do require it in
oftentimes other areas that if you are
you don't get reimbursed unless you are
specifically qualified to do a procedure
and or an exam so I I think for that
reason insurance reasons for Quality
reasons for ease of school systems
having a list of qualified providers
would be very helpful for many people I
think the list is fine I think the
question is going to be how do you get
on the
list right and and so I I think
philosophically we agree on it which is
that you know anybody who is
legitimately qualified to do it ought
ought to be suitable to do
it being somewhat cynical I see things
more in terms of you know there's
there's going to be a uh a gatekeeper
saying I I want you to go through the
following training programs and it'll
cost you this much in time and money uh
to get on the list to do something that
you probably learned how to do years ago
and know full well how to do but I want
you on my list um and so I I'm my
concern is that we're creating that kind
of a a bureaucracy that I think is
burdening to burdensome to to Medical
providers and um you know their time to
be better better spent caring for
patients again one push back that I
would give from my own experience is
that I was a board examiner for
orthopedic surgery I went out every July
for a week to reexamine it used to be in
the mid 80s that you once you were
boarded you were grandfathered for Life
the problem with that is that you were
grandfathered for life and that any new
techniques literature you didn't keep up
to date with because you weren't in in
in any way threatened to lose your board
certification but if you had but after
87 or 88 I forget exactly the date we
instituted research certification so
every 10 years you had to come back and
be recertified so it speaks to the fact
that yes somebody may have been doing
this for a long period of time but they
aware of the new techniques or the new
ways to examine um and again it could be
just opthomology it could be any other
sub specially but again it makes sure
that people are up to dat and qualified
to do the exam properly I think we're
completing a couple of things one is
there's the
screening which takes relatively minimal
amount of training and there's also I
exam so we're talking about screenings
not exams right so if we stay at the
screening side I think at that point in
time is that what's involved to be
appropriately trained to do the
screening I think the exams is being
done by the appropriate professionals
now optometrists and opthalmologists and
so forth so I don't think we're talking
about the exam here well I think that's
an important point to make because if
you are I wouldn't say only screening
but if you are screening
only then you are picking up a deficit
in a child who can't see the chalkboard
or they are falling behind in their
reading um competency and therefore it
triggers a an exam by a real qualified
person who can do split lamp or any
other opthalmologic examination and so
you're absolutely right we're talking
about screening not exam but they still
should be able to De demonstrate even
the minimal proficiency in screening I I
concur I think that's where so I'm
trying to figure out though is what
level of training do they need to do the
screening I could give my wife a call
and find out because she went through
the process even though she was a nurse
um to stay but I don't believe in
talking to her it was very difficult to
it doesn't even have to be a healthc
care professional in her opinion that
does the screening it's just as long as
they're trained so so I think we're
actually all pretty much in agreement on
this which is that it's yeah it's it's
important to know that people are
qualified but not to make the process
burdensome and Mr chair if I could you
had two other things I don't see this as
having a fiscal not need one because if
I heard it correctly it's currently
being covered by
Medicaid and that's what the state
controls so therefore there's no impact
of the budget because we currently pay
for it and number two I believe that's
the case yes and number two I concur
with you I I'm really reluctant when you
talk about giving an agency rulle making
Authority unless it's very narrow in
scope mhm so that's where I'm coming
from so so the other so I'll I'll list a
couple of other things and again some of
these are really minor and could be
fixed with small tweaks in language
um the beginning of the bill says
children ages 0 to
six the section 13 refers to children
under
six and so technically Al speaking does
are are those two the same thing or not
I think they're different I I think one
is zero through you know up to the day
before your seventh birthday and I think
the other one is um up until the day
before your sixth birthday uh I may be
wrong but that would be something I
would want clarification on
um the the
section
um there's a section that says every
child not reading at grade Lev by third
grade shall be referred uh by the school
physician or school
officials um I have to go look at it now
where are you um this is the
last four thank you yeah it's it's page
18 of the second page of the bill uh
page three of the document special
vision screening every child not reading
at grade level by third grade or at the
request of their teacher shall be
referred by the school physician or
School administrator to the parents or
Guardian for
examination and evaluation by a licensed
optometrist physician physician
assistant or you know again we could say
provider at this point they're not
saying screening they're saying
examination now I can tell you having
served on a school board for three years
having served part of that time as the
chair of the school board I have seen
multiple reports of where we are versus
grade level and there are a certain
percentage of students especially at the
beginning of the year who are not
reading at grade level um during coid
this was especially true my concern is
we're we're triggering a process because
this is a shall be
referred
um when there may be clear knowable
reasons why a child is otherwise not
reading at grade level um so I'm I'm
just a little bit concerned that this
is creating a creating a process that
that may be completely unnecessary but
if we lay it out in statute we're
telling people they have to do it it
says shall so that that was another
concern finally uh I think this is my
last
one
um I have a question about as to whether
this is a 28a violation um
so um representative Murphy you referred
to sort of the school board Contracting
with uh providers and this was sort of I
I guess part of me kind of thought of it
this way as well is that um if the
school is conducting the vision
screening either they're incurring some
kind of a training cost that they might
already be doing I don't know some but I
I suspect some may not not be to have a
school nurse or other other Personnel
trained in performing these Vision
screenings or they're Contracting with
an outside provider but there's a cost
associated with it potentially in any
case is that an unfunded mandate coming
down from the state on school districts
again that's a question it's a concern
about the current bill I don't know if
it's necessarily true um but I don't
know just going back to the previous
Point BAS basically this is sort of
saying
hey if if somebody's not reading at
third grade level it's not that we're
going to suggest a vision screening it's
that we're going to refer to the parent
or
guardian and we have to do it that they
will get an exam not a screening but a
full exam by a licensed uptop interest
physician etc etc and so it it just
feels to me like all of these issues
isues collectively add up to a bill that
needs a good deal more work than we
can can can do in in the next couple of
weeks um I I just feel like there's a
lot more that needs to happen with this
bill so that's that's kind of my my view
on it yeah and I I don't disagree with
that I mean you when you're looking at
that special screening vision screening
I I had some thoughts about that when I
was reading it again you know I I would
keep the sh because it is still
considered a uh an important Examination
for a child but it would be for not um
of said child for just evaluation by a
qualified provider um having said that
you mentioned that the unfunded mandate
for
a somebody who does the
screenings the question I have in my
mind oftentimes if you
are if you are willing to provide a
service in an institution whether it's a
school or a hospital you are responsible
personally for your own education for
your own certifications for your own
boards and the cost incurred by them
it's not usually picked up by somebody
else you you you you're responsible
because in a sense you are uh providing
a surface under your license um and as
such it could be an arrangement within
the school system that um the school
says yeah we're going to cover you know
that like many businesses cover you know
special training for their employees uh
or it may be stated to the um to the
teacher or whomever in the school that
you can do the screenings but you're
going to have to get the certification
on your own and you know so it doesn't
have to be necessarily a mandated
funding it could be an arrangement that
is mutually agreed upon in every
institution
um you know I have friends who have
businesses and up your Val and they
don't always provide you know healthare
for their employees you know I mean
that's up to them to decide you know
they get it or not uh but one of them
who is a plumber though he does not or
they do not provide Health Care they do
provide coverage for their special
training HVAC or whatever it might be
because they find that valuable to the
business so I mean that could be not
necessarily A unfunded mandate but it
may be an arrangement that is left to
the the school to say we will cover it
or it's up to you to provide your
certification if you want to do it that
sort of thing so
um again that's just off a couple
thoughts about when you mentioned that
before so okay and again for me it was
it was more of a question not a
definitive statement because I I'm not
sure whether it would be a 28a violation
yeah um any any other comments so you I
think you know you were said you were
doing a good deal of research as well
did you want to expand on that I think
part of what we're looking for if
boiling it down I would say this bill
could be trimmed down
significantly um through through an
amendment now I don't know
TimeWise how much time we have do we
have to have an amendment ready when we
discuss this in exact session or do we
have the rest of the year to work on an
amendment to get it through the bill
through through the committee what's our
timeline does anyone know um
I believe November 17th is the signoff
date in other words I think it has to be
out of
17th so I think that yeah bottom line we
would need to have an amendment to bring
to the full
committee
um when the full committee meets to
discuss this other stuff which means
that we would would presumably need to
have a an additional work session of
this group between now and then or we
could if it's okay with the chair not
know about representative Murphy I think
a lot of this will be tackle right
now through through our committee and
then bring an amendment to the exec
committee for them to then at that point
in time with our recommendation to
support the amendment that we draft
providing agreement with the amendment
and then at that point in time when we
have an ex session we could vote on the
amendment at that time versus Heaven has
come back to again work on the amendment
I think right now what I'm seeing is and
what I'm hearing anyways with
some quick wording and so forth we could
take a a Microsoft Word of of this and
just parse
it I mean I think we have the concerns
that we've addressed I think we can work
on the language to get it through versus
I'm open to that discussion my biggest
concern is that I feel like there's a
lot of potential problems here so
um it it feels to me like I I you you
believe that this it could be vastly
simplified I think vastly simplifying it
is is part of what needs to happen
um I guess I'm just concerned that
there's there's a lot of work to be I
think there's a lot of work to be done
to come up with a workable Amendment but
that's you know if if the if if it's the
majority of this working group wants to
proceed to try to craft an amendment
then you know by all means we can we can
route I think we take my my personal
opinion is take a Microsoft Word
document and probably take a
um aversion
to strike out I mean a lot of stuff here
doesn't have to be here number one is
Medicaid if you go to page
one line
six you don't have to fund a Medicaid
children's screening program unless
we're talking about an unfunded mandate
we could cross that bridge later on so I
don't see there's an issue with line six
quite frankly through 15 a lot of this
can just basically what trying to get to
is that the schools
shall provide the opportunity to a
child for a
screening and I I'm also wondering about
whether or not the 0 to six versus un
six is significant only because if they
cover it from 0 to 18 yeah then that age
doesn't really have any relevance does
it no I don't think so I I tend to agree
with you actually I think because it was
sort of said we want to create a
Medicaid Program for children ages Zer
to six and
then but they cover all way to 18 right
so they they're they're all covering it
all all three plans are covering it as
an essential health benefit up to age 18
yeah um
so Mr chair if I just on page two on
line six following up with the prepos of
Murphy there shall be vision screening
by a qualified individual period yep let
me so so what I'm doing right now is
exporting the PDF to Word okay um so I
have a Word
document and I'm going to turn on track
changes
um the first thing I'm gonna say is um
lines on the first page lines five
through 15 you can delete completely
yeah I'm actually I'm on the bill number
right now which is um
um a comment and and I don't I don't
believe that this can be changed in any
way we cannot change the title but well
I think we can change the title I don't
think we can I've seen amendments that
change the title we can't change the
bill number uh okay but the bill number
has an FN after
it and I would argue potentially it
should have an an L after it
well I think Finance could um redirect
it back to the committee if there's no
fiscal note okay so I'm just making a
note does it really need FN should it
have an L what's an L local meaning that
it has local an impact on local uh so if
you wanted to change the title or you
thought it was misleading title would
you add just in front of um children's
just mandatory
um just
delete the last within the state of
Medicaid
Program I I would I would not reference
Medicaid because this bill really is not
about Medicaid I I don't see it as such
so I was just thinking establishing a
mandatory children's vision screening
initiative no not a
mandatory
well I I it it establishes what we've
been talking about that it is to some
degree well yeah you're right in the
sense that if they can opt out then it
becomes not m
so okay would would Universal
work where are you or
Statewide children's vision
screening requirement period that
works represent of Murphy what are your
thoughts yeah I'm okay with that yeah
yeah um actually I'm going to I'm going
to suggest a slight difference
establishing a Statewide children's
vision screening requirement for
children in public
schools because that's what the bill
says does that um work I'm careful about
the word requirement because it's
mandate it seems to me it's an
initiative it's an
initiative or it's an initiative or
building Community
awareness what if you did title that you
just stated but instead of requirement
just initiative How would
establishing a Statewide children's
vision screening Initiative for
children entering Public Schools
sure in public school in public school
and I would say for those who are being
homeschooled why could not the parent
nurse there's no reason why they could
primary care or somebody like that well
again you're you're expanding
the scope of the Bild then
and what what I'm concerned about is
that we then have a cohort of children
outside of the school system that can
actually participate in school sports
they can participate in school
activities so why would they not allow
them to go to a screening if the parent
that I guess my I I'll just be blunt uh
do does it complicate the bill to start
bringing those things into it I I would
say it's a question of how we word it
okay so again the same thing I'm I'm
more into looking at this if you want to
make it really Statewide then once we
start parsing out and saying well these
children don't need to be considered
because they're in private school they
don't have to be considered because
they're homeschooled they're in a
religious school then all of a sudden
the broad initiative of taking care of
our children fundamentally
philosophically goes away okay I'm going
to say I think it it complicates it it
it it makes the
um I think there will be more objections
if if it is then take it
out um or leave out the word Public
School in the title at
least great I'll remove in public
schools School establishing Statewide
children's vision screening Initiative
for children uh children at school age
I'm yeah
um establishing a
Statewide vision screening get rid of
children's I had children in there twice
yeah um establishing a Statewide vision
screening Initiative for school age
children
yes
okay under
um yes so school age though yeah that
that doesn't cover the neonate or the
good point 0 to3 so um in in practice
neither does the bill no right but what
about just saying just stopping that
title at we can take it out of the title
yeah it's fine with me okay
um so I just took it out with the title
um analysis this bill establishes a
children's vision screening initiative
administered by the Department of Health
and Human
Services period done period
yeah where where were you now this is
analysis okay thank you I don't think
you need a second sentence at all right
um then we get down to enact
establishing etc etc in this case I'm
going to replace it with the title that
earlier
okay
um so to help with the next paragraph
there because it has a lot of stuff in
there we would want to eliminate
potentially how about just as I'm
reading this the you can just use the
words here and eliminate parts of it the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall uh provide now you go down four
lines shall provide vision screening
services to Children um
um to
Program from0 to 18 would you have would
you want have that more specific like
that so the Department of Health and
Human Services shall provide vision
screening oh but they're not provided no
no no so um that's right it should they
shall um
establish vision screening
um Initiative for children between ages
zero and 18 I would think that that's
all encompassing obviously right that's
what we're talking about
umun to me let me ask a question for a
moment if let's just skip down
to the next page page Tech uh line
pupils there shall be a vision screening
by a
qualified provider provider yep uh etc
etc does does
that does that address the fundamental
requirement because if
if the the the beginning of the bill
basically basally says the Department of
Health and Human Services shall seek
funding they shall get this you know as
part of the State Medicaid Program and
uh they should make they you know there
should be a a complete training program
available and um the commissioner shall
adopt
rules uh governing the administration of
the of the
initiative um including eligible
criteria frequency and type there's a
whole lot here that and and this is
again why I'm I'm concerned like can we
really accomplish this if we're doing
this
amendment what are we ask I mean what is
the do does HHS have any role in this um
I think so I'm just not totally clear on
what it is and we don't have anybody
from HHS here to provide that input so
this is where I'm I'm kind of concerned
that we're we're trying to do major
surgery on this bill and it just feels
like like there's too much and and so
having said that I I guess I feel like
the the the need of the bill is really
that second page starting on line
six Mr chair yes I think if we go back
and look at line six and what represent
Murphy talked about is a qualified
provider MH and then you can take the
rest of that and delete it results of
children's vision screening shall be
presented to the local school board I
think at this point in time the
appropriate place to send it is not the
school board but the
parents
[Music]
um so it's basically on line nine result
of the children's vision screening shall
be presented to the guardian or the
parent of the child could it be an
and and local school offici and then all
and also local school board I mean but
the school board I it's interesting
because when I first read that I
commented it
the school board does not want to or
need to know about specific health
conditions of specific individuals and
then I reread it and I said okay I don't
know how I saw School Board in that
because school board is not in that
sentence correct um it says school
officials so just a a sort of a point of
of order on that particular sentence
um so well and to the local school
officials on a form provided by the
local school
authorities do we in fact want it to be
a different form for every potentially a
different form for every school district
in the state now presumably the New
Hampshire school boards Association
could could publish a form and say hey
use this or the school Nurses
Association could do the same thing but
practically speaking do we want to do we
want a potentially a proliferation of
different kinds of
forms as a provider I think you would
want want to know that there's one form
that you use right then you get back
into who's going to create the
HHS you could yeah DHHS could create a
form standardized form to utilize but
that's going to go through rule making
um
or you could I mean part of but looking
at I think
the the CR the critical piece to this is
being sure that parents know what the
results
were and and at the same time when they
pres present the results what their
options are to deal with the
results was presented to their the
guardian and to local school officials
correct Guardian parent or school right
and local
officials because the form could be
created by HHS and placed in the um the
paragraph Roman jeel two up above there
basically you can do that yeah a form
right now the other thing which I would
say is that based upon what I saw in the
screenings the document I sent to you
folks or to myself
is how often you know if you come in on
grade
screening I look at representative
Murphy um I've been told that sometimes
in some schools it's K grade one grade
two and then it goes to four and so
forth so the question is even though
they failed or pass the first one at
kindergarten should they have one again
when they get the first grade I mean how
often do you have to do a screening
have or do leave it up to the local
school officials to determine the
frequency which the screening is done
well again in paragraph you know
paragraph Roman two you could basically
be another sentence that basically just
says um you know because they referen
the American Academy of Pediatrics they
the recommendation as to the U frequency
of
exams as determined by the American
opthalmologic Association and the um
Academy of Pediatrics that that works
yeah because that could change over time
will okay I'm trying to keep up with and
I'm and I'd like to kind of go through
this methodically if possible um and I
apologize because I'm struggling a
little bit with the way this exported to
word and the formatting is going to be
odd but I I I think I've got it under
um what I have at the top is the
Department of Health and Human Services
initiative
um what did we say before for for
18 okay
um we're gonna strike the seek funding
for
Medicaid as part of this Department's
budget for the bium ending June 30th
2025 and each B bium
thereafter then we've got the program
shall provide reim well actually it's
we're not doing reimbursements either
um that sentence that said Department of
Health and Human Services
shall provide um vision screening you
know the first sentence here vision
screening services children between zero
and 18 years of age
um uh by qualified providers that
encompasses everybody all that all that
sentence I would think screening by
qualified providers yeah I I don't even
think we need to say by qualified
providers at this point I think we say
that later and I think this
is Introduction my my concern is I don't
want to say the Department of Health and
Human Services shall provide Visions
it's they're going to establish the
initiative
or program call it what you will but
they're not going to be the ones
actually providing the screenings so I'm
concerned about using the word provide
yeah shall provide right um establish
um vision screening Initiative for
children vision screening services
Initiative for children between Z and 18
then we get again starting and and I'm
I've completely lost track of line
numbers but provide I think it's line 11
providers who choose to participate in
the
program and this kind of gets us back to
you know the is is is a position
who's qualified to to do a vision
screening but but hasn't
taken the initiative to to opt
in not qualified to do division
screening Mr chair yes instead of trying
to modify this which is going to be
problematic would it be better for us to
have a clean slate and have an amendment
replace
all can you start over yes I I I think
that that that's what it's looking like
and again this is this is where I I'm
concerned that we're we're really
we're deciding to write a bill from
scratch essent essentially and there's a
lot there's a lot to consider here
there's a lot to clean up here and
there's a lot
of input from stakeholders that I think
we need and aren't aren't in a position
to take unless we have another meeting
and we cannot do that meeting via
virtual meeting is that correct we we
cannot do it virtually
um we would have to get we would have to
request an amendment from ol we
certainly can do that I know that they
are
um under a lot of pressure right now we
have over 800 house bills we have 300
and some odd I 312 Senate bills
um and they have a
so yeah I mean my concern is that we're
we're to me this feels like an interim
study bill I have I got to be honest
with you it feels to me like we're we're
performing major surgery on it and and
that it it makes me uncomfortable I
don't disagree with you there because it
sounds like we're trying to Wordsmith
this to the point where we're going to
be satisfied I'm concerned that we'll
get to the end of this short meeting and
still not have a product that will
really all that comfortable with Z right
and and that we we should expect a bunch
of fresh input from stakeholders
including DHHS and the New Hampshire um
optometrist Association and others
um that have not I mean what they've
been looking at is a very very different
Bill than what we will be ultimately
looking at I don't think it's a non-
gerine Amendment situation in other
words I don't think we're compelled to
hold another hearing but practically
speaking I I don't think it makes sense
to move move forward
legislation where we have not provided
an opportunity if we're making changes
that major where we have not provided an
opportunity for people to to voice their
support or opposition or concerns and I
I you know I I've been listening in
participating but I I've also come to
the same agreement or conclusion in my
mind that I'm not sure right now we can
make it satisfactory number one number
two there may be other people that would
want to participate and again it's that
0 to 18 is it all children 0 to 18 or is
it the the ones that are homeschooled or
whatever um what would you know the rul
making Authority for them to come up
with the rules that were assigning to
HHS so I don't disagree I don't want to
kill the bill because I think it's an
don't I think it's important um I think
this
if we do interim study we're not going
to get something for at least another
year so so let me let me
offer that's all an Al an alternate yeah
suggestion and I still think we
need stakeholder input on
this so I'm going to read you RSA
200 section 32 it's not very
long and you'll you'll recognize I some
of the
language physical examination of pupils
there shall be a complete physical
examination by a licensed physician
physician assistant or advanced practice
registered nurse of each child prior to
or upon first entry into the public
school system and thereafter as often as
deemed necessary by the local school
Authority the result of the child's
physical examination shall be presented
to the local school officials on a form
provided by the local school authorities
no physical examination shall be
required of a child whose parent or
Guardian objects thet in writing on the
grounds that such physical examination
is contrary to the child's religious
tenants or and
teachings that is short it is
simple um I don't necessarily
like everything about it but it's short
and it's
simple
um is that current law that is current
law rsa2 200 section 32 and again a lot
of the language in House Bill 580 or not
a lot but some some of the language in
House Bill 580 is clearly drawn from
this section so it's uh
200 section
sanitation
and
the house bill 580 does not propose to
amend that section what it proposes is
to insert a section after that
section
so what why are we going through all of
this if it's already
there this says complete physical
examination so and and the the the bill
is aimed specifically at
vision screening and I think it's also
the younger child too right because that
says before school right well no it's
the it's actually the same language it's
upon first entry into the public school
system and thereafter but what that
excludes is a neonate or that zero to
three right and I think what there this
bill also does is expand it to that
early you know childhood neonate to
three years old or four years old when
they enter school so well but
practically
speaking it it that that's where I say
the the current bill is kind of
confusing because it it it goes into
Medicaid and that we want to establish a
Medicaid vision screening program for
ages 0 to six and then it
says essentially the same language we
see here except instead of physical
examination it says vision
screening and it says up to age six
which excludes a child who may be
entering you know maybe turning six in
September in the middle of September of
the year that they enter first grade or
it could be a child who who's who's
coming in from another state and they're
nine years old and they haven't had that
vision screening so the the way it's
written currently
is confusing contradictory Etc I I guess
I'm suggesting that if if you wanted a
path to I mean it sounds like the
fundamental concern here
is
that we would like kids to to get this
we want parents to be aware of it we
want parents to have a choice to opt
out but and so so so that we can
catch these kinds of problems
early um it's it's it's interesting in
the letter from the New
Hampshire Optometric
Association they note that you know
because of the definition of vision care
as an essential benefit under the
ACA
um they they say you know we're we're
happy that that you know that's now
available to families however it is not
being utilized um in other words not
being fully
utilized um any such any program created
by HB 580 should supplement and not
detract from or delay the utilization of
existing annual comprehensive eye exam
benefit um so if I could interject right
here so what what I'm hearing then as I
look at this it says also so this bill
it sounds to me then came about to fund
because the first sentence is HHS shall
seek funding from Medicaid but that
funding is already existent and so
therefore if if we're targeting then a
group before they get into school but we
would also like to have it be that that
group from zero to when they enter
School whether that's four five or six
then if there's a mandate who is the
Mandate placed upon is it the parents
because they're not already in the
school system right so it seems to me
this bill was initiated to seek funding
from Medicaid that was already present
for 0 to six but
then where I'm getting confused with
this versus what's already in statute is
the necessity of this bill if it's
already funded and if it's trying to
create a mandate of examination from
zero to six or when they enter School
who's the Mandate on at that point
because it's not the school they're not
in school yet is it the parents is it
it's the parents yeah right um so so so
and and it's a I mean let's be honest
it's a low bar I mean it it's anybody
almost everybody who has a um almost
everybody who has health insurance or if
they have Medicaid uh in New
Hampshire it's not going to cost them
anything out of pocket there are some
and if if we if we were to remove the
the language around um you know you can
object for any reason not just for
religious reasons then
I think we're we're pretty much covered
my I guess
my I'm still going to say I think that
interim study is is the way to go with
this because I think there are so many
un unanswered questions having said that
I will offer a suggestion I don't know
that I will necessarily support this
suggestion but it's it's I want to throw
out the idea anyway which is if we look
at RSA 200 section
32 um we could potentially boil down the
intent that we're talking about here to
Simply
adding a few words to this section or
more or less duplicating this section
and replace physical examination with
vision screening um you know the the the
the the first version would be there
shall be a complete physical examination
comma including vision screening comma
um and the the the second version would
be copy and paste this whole thing and
replace physical examination with vision
screening I still you know I I'm not
crazy about the contrary to the child's
religious tenants and teachings I prefer
your version which is unless the parent
objects period
um so that that would be the really
simple way I think to get to where we
you know what I'm hearing in terms of
intent I think as we listen to this
conversation I'm beginning to understand
where the
ey Physicians are coming up with some
sort of an an objection because the way
I read this
now the child's required to get a
complete physical eye
exam which is done by one of the
providers if we allow for a screening in
addition to the physical exam I think
their concern is that parents won't go
to the ey doctor for the exam and rely
upon the screening itself that's one
issue yes number two there's no funding
in Medicaid for a vision screening it's
only for the exam so I think what
they're trying to do is create a funding
mechanism for those who do a screening
so that they would not have an unfunded
mandate that's kind of what I'm boiling
it down to and I
think if we go back to the bill and just
look at 20 col
32 and work on that piece of of it and
leave everything else out of
it I think we're going the right
direction we don't need the rest of it's
trying to come up with a funding
mechanism for screenings with Medicaid
and so forth Etc because that's where
the state has any control over it I
don't think we have to worry about
funding the screenings per se although
it could be a 28a violation that I don't
know um but for the most part schools
are probably doing most of this anyways
and I think where the eye doctors are
concerned about is that because if we
weaken this language in the current
statute then their concern would be that
parents won't go to the eye doctor for
the physical exam they'll rely upon the
screening which is not a bad thing so
are you saying that the examination is
covered by Medicaid but screenings are
not right so is that an entirely
different conversation then that to to
is it trying to then establish funding
for Medicaid or just children's vision
screening number one and my sense would
be the opthalmologists want to decrease
and I don't know how to capture this in
a bill they want to decrease the time
from uh exam to referral so you know
what they're saying is we want to catch
this these this pathology early you know
but how do you do that if a child is not
already in school right I mean yeah how
are you going to do that how do you
mandate that I'm not sure how you do
that isn't that part of the Wild Child
visit it it it should be
so but if is it done by people that are
qualified to do it number one number two
is it reimbursed for them to do that
screening I and that's where I'm going
to push back a little bit with the
represent of Murphy is that right now
you have a physician doesn't say what
physician it could be a pathologist most
likely not but it could be you could
have a PA you could have a nurse
practitioner who have have not the
appropriate training to do it an eye
exam but according to the law they can
do it mhm and I think it's back to my
concern is that as you mentioned before
it's a qualified
provider not just a provider with a
license so the the way I'm hearing it
again is that this bill seems to me as
it's written now and the intent was to
do two things maybe more but um to
provide funding for screening number one
one which may not be done right now
number two is to decrease the time
between you know the onset of pathology
the exam and then the referral meaning
how do you pick up the very young child
I think so and having said that I'm not
sure we can right now
then rewrite this whole bill you know to
concerns that's why you know it may be
as I go around the barn with this that
interim study may be the more
appropriate way to proceed with it I
think we're probably coming to the same
conclusion I would say the First full
page of this bill could be deleted
completely the only place I see a lot of
Merit here is on the second page
starting with section three which is the
screening or vision screening of pupils
and pups me and I is not students so I
think that's kind of the Cor of the
whole thing is that
section I think the lines 18 to
25 um getting down to third grade and so
forth and trying to be sure it should be
done I think if you go back to looking
that with the frequency in which
screenings are accomplished that would
be picked up at that time anyways but I
think the real heart of what we're
trying to get to is on page two line six
through 15 the rest of it we could
jettison
and that's why I said that I I think the
the essence of what we're talking about
is is really
taking 200 R RSA 200 section 32 yep and
creating a more or less a duplicate copy
of that in the form of RSA
232a um or just adding you know adding
vision screening to to the existing
statute although the exist existing
statute is Under The Heading
um health and I'd have to go look at it
but
um I I I still feel like we are
operating with incomp well I feel like
I'm operating with incomplete
information because I I was given to
understand that under
Medicaid vision care generally speak
broadly speaking is is covered so I may
be wrong about that but the screening
are not okay so you're you're sure of
that okay
that's the reason for it being is that
in the school system talk to my wife was
a school nurse they can build Medicaid
for certain services this is not one of
them okay so that's that's four five
years ago so it may have changed but
that's okay so that kind of gets us back
to you know is the int is the is the
original Bill than creating a new
Medicaid Program or Medicaid um coverage
for vision
screenings necessary if you wanted to
implement that limited section that that
you just
identified I don't think so because most
schools today do hearing en Vision
screenings so it's it's there the
question comes down to is how often
are the parents aware of it and that's
part of I think this is more of a
communication education issue is
building awareness of what can be done
by the school nurse as a screening
process and as long as we allow for the
parent to opt out which we do with the
other dental and so forth then at that
point in time the parent has to give
their explicit permission to do the
screening
so I have a procedural question and I'm
not I think you're you're the most
likely with the longest tenure here in
the legislature you're the most likely
to know the answer if we go interim
study does that preclude us from acting
on the Legislation during this bium
yes
okay one of the things I could suggest
is that this is going to come out of the
the house it's going to go to the other
side of the wall and it's going to have
a full hearing on that side of the wall
so I do hear the concerns by the chair
about having other people weigh in on
this and it's a very logical wise
concern but be mindful the fact is even
no matter what we do
here it's going over to the other
chamber and it's going to have a full
hearing and everyone including
DHHS um the opthalmologist optometrist
school boards are going to weigh on it
so they'll have another bite at the
Apple yeah and I'm going to argue that
unless it's waved by Finance it's also
going to go through Finance correct um
so and and having said that I generally
like to take the position that I don't
want to act on a bill I I always want to
act on a bill as if you know my decision
is is ultimately the one that will that
will prevail and um not depend on
someone else to fix something and so I I
I totally get what you're saying um
um I I guess I want to ask
if you know where what's the what's the
will of the committee regarding interim
study versus an amendment and if it's an
amendment do you have a suggestion as to
what that would look
like I
yes I do have a suggestion about the
amendment um I would focus on the
amendment on line six
through 15 on page two and everything
else I would probably
jettison as far as another bite at the
Apple you're right I'd like to have
things come out based upon doing it
correctly not relying upon other people
to do it now the option to an amendment
is going to interim
study which means is is going to be dead
for this year and we're going to have to
rely upon the next legislative body to
pick up the bill if someone even wants
to do it because it's going to have to
vium so and representative Murphy so
what I was thinking about because I was
looking at that and I agree that that's
already in statute colon
32A that could be changed obviously to
to disqualified providers but it still
gets to the um child prior to or upon
entry into public school
system
and so the two things that I think we
I'm not sure that this resolves is the
Medicaid funding for screening number
one and number two the the how do you
pick up the
child before they get to school age you
know before they get to school so and I
I think I think when this bill was
probably written the intent because they
put 0 to six was specifically to get to
that younger child in some way or manner
to um have a screening done um they
probably knew that there was no funding
for screening so I suspect that funding
should be if we're going to do this
would be part of the bill but number
two in to me it's how do you get how do
you get the examination of that very
young child done
um I I don't think just simply having a
reimbursement you know carrot will
necessarily always get it done for the
child for every child I totally agree I
think until they get to school or get
into you know prek or k some level of
school there's no gatekeeper if you will
right to be sure the parent is doing
what we think they should be doing so in
in that we cannot mandate the no parents
activity then perhaps the simplest way
in head in in medicine would be
therefore if you provide Medicaid
funding for
screening would that then be enough of
an initiative to have um screenings done
by qualified providers um I'm not sure
about that I don't know if that's going
to encourage the parent to get to a
provider um and then on top of that with
the provider quite frankly is going to
do the work based upon a
screening the funding of a screening
which is different than an exam I think
the real challenge here is it's like
lead poisoning if you don't get the
parent involved by the time they get to
first and second grade and they've had
lead poisoning it's
over the real time to get to the child
is between the ages of zero and
two so I don't know you rais a good
point representative Murphy I don't know
how we can encourage parents to do the
screenings with it's light screening
hearing you raise a good point well so
that's why I think that the simplest
amendment to this is to include um a
screening exam because at least takes
away one of the roadblocks to having a
child before they get to school examined
in in SC Not examined screen for their
Vision because I was thinking about how
else are you going to mandate that
they're not in the public domain they're
not in school they're at home
so perhaps that the the best way to
approach that is to say as this bill
started out maybe that was their initial
intent was that there they knew that
there was no reimbursement funding for
screening so if there is Medicaid funds
available for
screening but why do they if if
currently Medicaid will pay for a full
eye
exam why would you
then look for funding for screenings
because they can go to the eye doctor
today at any age and get a full exam
fully paid
for so you get back to the parental
responsibility right that's saying can I
can I suggest a so so based on what I've
heard and and I'm gonna say I don't
think we're going to solve the this like
0 to2 or 0o to five problem with right
now but based on what I'm hearing
hearing I have taken that section and I
have changed a little bit of language so
I'm going to read the whole thing and
then I'll go back and sort of spell out
where I've specifically where I've
changed the language vision screening of
pupils there shall be a vision screening
or Vision
examination by a qualified medical
provider of each child prior to or upon
first entry into the public school
system and thereafter as often as deemed
necessary by the local school Authority
the result of the child child's vision
screening shall be presented to the
local school
guardians or
Guardians on a form provided by the
local school
authorities no vision screening
[Music]
examination shall be required of a
child who I'm going to say no vision
screening or examination shall be
required of a child whose parent or
Guardian objects th to in writing period
a student is not required to submit to
any vision screening required by this
section if the parent or Guardian
submits a statement that the student
received a comprehensive ey and vision
examination in the last 12 months or if
the student has a current diagnosis of
per permanent vision loss so the changes
that I made are in the first line there
shall be a vision screening or Vision
examination which solves I think solves
the Medicaid problem because that's
available the funding part yes yes uh by
a qualified medical
provider uh and then I added that the
information will go to school officials
and parents or
Guardians on a form provided Etc no
vision screening or examination shall be
required of a child whose parent or
Guardian objects therefore to in writing
I crossed out on the grounds that such
examination is contrary to the child's
religious tenants and teachings so it's
just if they object in writing period a
student is not required to submit to any
vision screening required okay so that
that those are all the changes so that
would be only that paragraph would be
the amendment to
200 you tell me because I think you're
you're probably the one who would be
sponsoring the amendment I I'm not sure
if I want to sponsor the amendment or
not well Dr think this is a vast impr
mury he's sponsor of the bill so if he
wants to bring the amendment forward I'd
be more than glad to do it it's Nancy
Murphy oh it's Nancy Murphy yeah uh oh
okay I'll I'll be more than glad to
bring It Forward I would make I don't
even mind bringing it Forward myself I'm
just saying okay
than so so can I make it recommend it to
the chair though I think yes on your
wording though we talked about if we
have the local school authorities create
the form we're going have a variety of
forms versus a form developed by the
Department of Health Human
Services and I subsequently so so I
could go either way on that I
subsequently noticed that rsa2 200
section 32 already says um on a form
provided by local school authorities so
for the physical exam it's already by by
local school authorities so um
it it is a it was more of a question
than
a major
concern so the question still stands you
know which which do you think is
appropriate given the fact that we've
been doing this per since what 2009 at
least um with a local school Authority
Forum I okay with
it okay so because in my mind that
really simplifies it IT addresses the
reimbursement by Medicaid at least for
scening
it signifies or you know specifies a
qualified
provider and recognizing that you
necessarily can't mandate what a parent
does with their children before they get
to school and they in the public domain
period so I would be okay with that okay
so I am emailing to both of you the
language that I just read and it has any
changes highlighted in
red and including
language that has been struck out um so
assuming that that is the the amendment
as it will or or extremely close to the
amendment as it would go to actually
make me let me make one more
change
um which is the title um we we ought to
also
consider the title a change to the title
bill to to something like
uh well let's let's see what the RSA
says
um yeah the r the RSA
um the RSA the existing RSA just simply
says physical examination of pupils so
I'm going to um suggest that whoever
sponsors the amendment come up with a
change to to the to the title as well
that is more suitable to what the
amendment now actually says so would it
be establishing um
um Medicaid funding for children's
vision screening initiative but it's not
Medicaid it's not Medicaid funding at
this point there's no change to Medicaid
funding it's simply we're including it
now um well know what we're doing what
we're doing is no we're not CH we would
not be changing anything about Medicaid
at all we'd Simply Be we'd actually be
changing the the requirement from it can
be vision screening or it can be a
vision examination and if it's an Vision
exam Medica it's probably a lot more
expensive but Medicaid covers it right
okay okay
so um or a school could decide that they
want to provide that as just part of
what they do but that's not a 21 28a
violation because they're making the
choice to do it yeah so that change in
first sentence basically would say that
Medicaid is going to cover exams and or
screenings I'm I'm going to say I I
think what we're suggesting and correct
me if I'm wrong representative Merchant
but I think what is being suggested is
is replace the entire bill with what I
just read exactly so the the bill
therefore would not mention Medicaid it
would not create make any changes to
Medicaid in fact it would not require
the Department of Health and Human
Services to do anything
um and I would argue that the finance
committee would probably take a look at
this and
say why why is it coming back to us well
because the original bill was marked
with a with a fiscal note
um so so I think though it does not
mention Medicaid it effectively does
cover the screening though because it's
in the previous Bill the way this is
written somebody who needs to get that
that vision screening
um and I should probably add because the
title says vision screening of pupil
pupils we should probably say vision
screening or
examination
screening is not paid for by medicator
most anyone okay because it's not part
of your medical benefit the exam is
right so if you're a
parent logical thing to do if you go to
an eye doctor is have an exam screen no
I by adding that it it makes it better I
get it but it gives it gives the school
the opportunity yeah to offer a
screening in L which is going to be
where the eye doctor going push back and
say wait now you're saying they can get
to the school system with only a
screening and not a physical exam right
so that Mak so and another procedural
note and you know probably better than I
is you know the chairman has sent that
to us all that's what we would
theoretically prop propos to the
committee when we meet the HHS
committee if there's any simple word
smithing that's not a non-gain change
can we do that without a committee
reconvening my understanding is yes I
mean what what we are doing is we I mean
if if there's a and that's why I say
whoever sponsors the amendment I'm I'm
open to right leaving it to the
amendment sponsor to determine what an
appropriate title would
be and and and in fact I'm I'm slightly
changing what I sent you because what I
didn't include in that was the beginning
of that section where it says new
section vision screening of pupils amend
RSA 2 200 by inserting after section 32
the following new section so I've added
that and I've also changed it from
vision screening or examination of
pupils um so that examination is in
there as well
okay Mr chair we basically taken 200
Colum 32 and revising that or are we
taking colon 32A and adding it to the
statute we are taking 32A which is part
of the bill correct we are making some
changes to it to reflect some concerns
like not listing all of the various
types of providers but simply saying
qualified provider and some other
changes like exam adding
examination um so again those changes
are all in the the version that I just
sent you but I'm going to send you a new
version M uh which again almost exactly
the same but before we proceed let me
just for the sake of absolute Clarity
time so this would be a a an amendment
to replace the entire uh we an amendment
to change the title to something
appropriate as deemed by the
the amendment
sponsor and then the the body of the of
the amendment would be replace
everything after the enacting Clause
with the following new section vision
screening or examination of pups amend
RSA 200 by inserting after section 32
the following new section am mend RSA
232a vision
screening or examination of pupils there
shall be a vision screening or Vision
examination by a qualified medical
provider of each child prior to or upon
first entry into the public school
system and thereafter as often as deemed
necessary by the local school Authority
the result of the child's vision
screening shall be presented to the
local school officials and parents or
Guardians on a form provided by the
local school authorities no vision
screening or examination shall be
required of a child whose parent or
Guardian objects th to in writing period
a student is not required to submit to
any vision screening required by the
section if the parent or Guardian
submits a statement that the student
received a comprehensive eye and vision
examination in the last 12 months or if
the student has a current diagnosis of
permanent vision
loss so that is what I'm here ing
um we're interested in proposing not to
throw a monkey wrench into it but I'm
going to if I look
at 200 col 32A and look at 200 colon 32
we have I think a potential conflict
between the two sections the first
section under the 32 you can only opt
out for religious tenants or teachings
under 32A we're allowing them to opt out
period so in essence one part of the
statute is saying you only can opt out
based upon this reason and the other one
says well I can opt out for any
conflict I had considered that you know
we might want to propose going back to
32 and removing that however I think
that that gets us into non- gerain
Amendment right position okay um sorry
and and
so I I would be inclined to Simply say
you know this is this is how this
section will look if this passes I agree
with that not to get into the Weeds
about it but um just the title of the
vision screening of pupils is there a
need to have a pups in there versus just
vision
screening it's in the education statute
so I don't I don't actually think it is
and um although representative Merchant
said it's pupils as an I not pupils as
in students I've actually read it as
pupils as in students so okay um so
considering that that would be a a a an
a non-material change uh but as I have
read it I think that is what we are
agreeing ought to be proposed at least
and again I'm
not I'm not sure yet where I stand on it
I think I'm I generally feel like this
whole thing needs a lot of work but um
it certainly is something I could live
with um
motion I'll make a motion to accept
the revised language for the bill 580
FN and to bring that revision as a form
of an amendment to our committee full
committee during the executive
session I can second that okay
um so are you recommending ought to pass
with
Amendment yes okay so we have a motion
by representative
Merchant we have a second by
representative
Murphy and um we do not
have I'm going to say in drafting for
the
amendment and
um will who wants to take responsibility
for getting that to OSS and asking them
to make a formal make the formal changes
and presumably you might both want your
name on the amendment but one of you
needs to take lead I can go either way
if yeah sure if you wanna that's fine
send it to me I'll send it to LS L okay
y sure um all right
so proba stop stop by on the way
out all right so
um so we have an so the motion on on the
floor is
otpa
um so for the sake of formality I will
do a roll call Representative
Merchant I representative Murphy
yes and
I I'm going to be a no um so that's
going to be a two to
one and um I believe that that completes
our business for the day is there
discuss okay with that I thank you for
your your uh participation here and I
will close the hearing or the
subcommittee work
you